I have professional camerawoman my wife
Carmen is gonna be shooting these videos
and I want to talk about exposure
because I think it's extremely important
right now I listen to these two these
patterns I read them I have my book
handy all the time if I get in five
minutes of listening or I'm sitting here
at my desk and I'm waiting for some
software to work its way through or
whatever I have this handy I can look at
it but when I read or listen what
matters to me is the exposure to
meaningful content
I don't worry about whether I remember
the meaning of words I don't worry about
whether it's totally clear to me I know
that if I'm exposing myself to content
that's more or less meaningful
eventually the brain is going to get
used to it and so I just continue along
and I talk to myself on the one hand to
to sort of to simple stuff like this and
over and over again hearing the phrases
reading the phrases and at the other end
of the spectrum is the material that I
bring in from Chosun Ilbo and because
the content has to be interesting and
meaningful the simple phrases in that
the patterns are not so meaningful but
the other stuff that I listen to I'm
doing a lot of Chosun Ilbo and I'll
throw it to you later on because what I
was using before the voice of Russia
Radio Free tolson which we have in our
in our library it's difficult for me to
understand when I listen to it I can
read it and understand it but I've read
it and listened to it so often now that
it's boring to me so I've moved away
from that I'm reading Chosun Ilbo elbow
but I will get back to that other
content the main thing is exposure
exposure without worrying about it and I
don't worry about whether I can produce
it if I if I listen to sit listening to
some structure here in this in the
grammar based you know pattern book all
I worry about is you know is it is it
coming at me am I getting exposed to it
I don't worry about whether I can
actually use it or speak it because I
know in time that I will be able to so I
sit here where in my work area
and if there's a slow moment like if I'm
on the phone I was on the phone just
Greece just now with Camtasia trying to
figure out how to combine sort of views
of our website with video and they
explained it to me and I was able to use
this while waiting for them to come on
the phone so I did be looking up my book
if I have a minute or two I can be
reading some sample phrases that's right
I'm I'm preparing myself for all this
kind of exposure like I have this book
here on Korean history and it's all
written in characters and I'm stead of
sort of licking my chops but I don't
want to start into it until I know the
Korean pronunciation for all these
characters and it's all more exposure an
exposure it's part of that that the sort
of three keys to my new journey that I
mentioned so many times first of all the
the willingness to spend the time which
is exposure the attitude another is the
interest you like it and the third thing
is this noticing and it's not just an
ability to notice it's the desire to
notice the will the determination I want
to notice what's going on the language
and these are things that you develop
and the more that you notice the more
new things you can notice all based on
lots of meaningful exposure and that's
the lesson for today thank you